bonsoir pardon de vous avoir fait
attendre mais nous étions je vais y
revenir avec le ministre ça devrait
quelques-uns d'entre eux d'entre vous
fortes occupées
je suis heureux de me retrouver devant
vous et l engagement que j'avais pris le
6 août dernier revenir revenir pour
cette date
j'y reviendrai aussi ô combien
symbolique et ce centenaire revenir
aussi pour rendre compte et poursuivre
ceux qui avait été lancée le 6 août ici
même
deux jours après l'explosion et la
catastrophe qui avait frappé en son
coeur déroule sa population et tout le
liban alors je veux avant tout chose
peut-être justement commencé par rendre
compte
pour répondre à l'urgence qui est
toujours là même quand l'actualité
internationale concentre reconcentre sur
d'autres drames
je veux ici les redire que nous
détourneront jamais les yeux de c'est
l'urgence de soutien pour peuple
libanais et donc faire le point comme je
m'y étais engagé comme je lé fais ce
matin avec plusieurs ong mais aussi les
nations unies et notre ambassadeur sur
le soutien qui a été apportée et revenir
sur la suite la france a donc agi dès le
lendemain de l'explosion par elle-même
de toutes ses forces et nous continuons
de le faire état collectivités locales
entreprises citoyens notre armée le
ministère évidemment le quai d'orsay
ministère de l'intérieur nos ong avec
beaucoup de volontaires et nos
collectivités territoriales un pont
aérien et maritime a été mise en place
huit vols et de navires affrétés par le
ministère des armées un vol affrété par
le groupe cma-cgm dès le 5 août est
cependant permis de déployer près de 140
personnels d'acheminer milton dead
en nature un troisième navire vient
d'arriver à traiter par la fondation
cma-cgm avec de l'aide en nature
provenant de l'état des collectivités
territoriales des ong du secteur privé
et ce titre je veux aussi remercier
l'ensemble de la délégation qui
m'accompagne et avec beaucoup de chefs
d'entreprises mais aussi de grandes
filières cjce des céréales ou du lait
qui montre l'engagement du tissu
économique français
l'engagement de nos grandes entreprises
qu'il s'agisse de sanofi saint gobain ou
plusieurs autres qui étaient là pour
aider aux soins la reconstruction 700
militaires ou étaient des coûts de
déployer travail
nous l'avons vu ce matin en parfaite
coordination avec elle les fall sur
place pour le déblaiement d'urgence et
nombre d'actions 140 personnels et
experts techniques ont été déployés
sauveteur déblayeur marins pompiers
gendarmerie police judiciaire si colog y
compris pour les besoins de l'enquêté
sur l'origine de l'explosion
et il était nécessaire comme je l'avais
dit ici il ya trois semaines que sept
ans qu'elle se fasse avec l'apport d'une
expertise internationale pour sa
crédibilité parce que le peuple libanais
le droit d'exiger la vérité je veux dire
ici que sur le plan technique cette
coopération se déroule bien et plusieurs
échanges ont été organisées et effectif
entre les services d' enquête libanais
et nos propres services une aile
médicale a été apportée pour faire face
aux conséquences de l'explosion et à la
pandémie avec 38 tonnes de matériel
médical et de médicaments le ministre de
la santé est là qui nous accompagnent
qui a pu aussi non seulement accompagné
cette aide ces déploiements mais évaluer
avec l'ensemble des équipes des ong et
des homologues libanais les besoins à
venir une aide alimentaire a été
mobilisée le 900 tonnes et des matériaux
de reconstruction pour 64 tonnes les
objectifs fixés le 6 août ont donc donné
lieu à l'ensemble de ses actions que je
récapitule ici de manière très brève
cette action bilatérale nous avons
complété par une mobilisation
internationale le 9 août avec les
nations unies nous avons organisé une
conférence internationale de soutien
beyrouth et au peuple libanais qui a
permis de mobiliser 250 millions d'euros
et un appui matériel massif et nous
continuerons sollicité la communauté
internationale à l'occasion de
l'assemblée générale des nations unies
dans le même esprit nous nous assurons
aussi que cet appui se fait dans le
cadre que nous avions défini
c'est à dire dans la transparence au
bénéfice direct de la population et en
partenariat avec la société civile
ce matin les changes que nous avons
tenus sur le tonnerre aux côtés des
équipes françaises européennes et
internationales des nations unies et de
la société civile pour faire le point de
la situation a permis de montrer des
véritables avancées des résultats mais
aussi des lacunes
il y a encore trop dead qui arrive nous
sommes en train de lister les les pays
et les entreprises qui ne passe pas par
la plate forme organisée par des nations
unies et il y a encore des rumeurs je
dis ça parce que nous n'avons pas pu
établir les preuves mais ted qui eux
pourraient être détournés n'ont pas de
l'aide qu'ils passent par le canal des
nations unies et par cette plateforme
qui travaille en direct avec les ong les
hôpitaux ou les services publics avec un
suivi mais bien d'elle qui suivrait
d'autres canaux et qui aujourd'hui deux
milieux sur les réseaux sociaux dans les
échanges qu'on peut avoir avec les ong
des dénonciations demande de
transparence relationnel s'agit pas ici
de l'aide française ni de l'aide
européenne qui passe par le truchement
d'un tel centre des nations unies et
donc nous allons clarifier ce point pour
que les choses s'améliorent
on a aussi lu ce matin le besoin
d'améliorer encore la coordination entre
les nations unies et l'ensemble des
associations et ong impliquées tout ce
qui est améliorée de taille qui va nous
occuper dans les prochaines semaines ne
doit en rien
oubliée la mobilisation exceptionnelle
depuis le 4 août ce qui est d'abord une
mobilisation des libanaises et des
libanais pour eux mêmes pour leurs
frères leurs soeurs leurs amis leurs
quartiers leurs peuples et qui est
absolument exemplaire avec une jeunesse
on voit présente dans toutes les
associations et derrière un soutien donc
de nos ong des ong internationales et de
l'ensemble de notre communauté
dans certains domaines nous avons réussi
à parer aux besoins les plus urgents
mais le travail reste colossal et au
delà même des conséquences directes de
l'explosion je veux ici cité dans la
durée quatre priorités que nous allons
poursuivre la santé évidemment pour
faire face donc aux conséquences de
l'explosion de du 4 août mais aussi à la
pandémie qui accélère depuis très
fortement et la réalité de l'épidémie du
coc u19 s'est profondément modifiée en
quelques semaines notre soutien aux
centres de santé primaire sera renforcée
de même que celui que nous apportons à
l'hôpital hariri nous étions avec le
ministre il y à quelques heures avec les
équipes de l'hôpital mais aussi celle de
la croix-rouge et de l'afd car nous
avons ce partenariat exemplaire en la
matière et 7 millions d'euros
supplémentaires seront apportées pour
aider l'hôpital hariri qui concentrent
véritablement le traitement des patients
atteints du coc vite 19 et occupe un
rôle extraordinaire
à côté de ça l'aide continuera d'être
déployé à l'ensemble des hôpitaux y
compris les hôpitaux privés qui joue un
rôle très important et qui ont pu aussi
bénéficier de l'aide bilatérale en
particulier de fondations et de la
france après la santé celle alimentaire
deuxième priorité que nous allons
continuer de poursuivre pour nous
assurer que les besoins immédiats sont
garantis construire des projets de
relance économique et de soutien au
secteur agricole dans la durée je citais
la filière céréalière et la filière
laitière ce sont deux exemples très
important et je veux saluer la
mobilisation exemplaire de celle ci mais
nous allons continuer de mobiliser nos
filières en la matière et elles sont au
rendez vous organisé structuré le faire
aussi en partenariat pour soutenir la
filière libanaise et régionale et le
faire aussi en partenariat avec les
grands transporteurs j'ai cité la
fondation cma-cgm mais le groupe
évidemment joue un rôle extrêmement
important
troisième priorité c'est l'éducation qui
est une priorité absolue alors que la
rentrée a été reporté il faut
impérativement que les enfants
retrouvent le chemin de l'école et les
étudiants celui de l'université c'est un
problème que beaucoup de nos pays ont
été touchés par le copil 19
on tue à vivre pendant le temps du
confinement il est évidemment aggravé
par l'explosion les difficultés
économiques et sociales
ici au liban mais c'est l'avenir du pays
qui se joue est dans un pays qui a
toujours su être rendez-vous de
l'éducation et de l'excellence de celle
ci beaucoup d'enfants que j'ai
rencontrés dans les hasards de nos
déplacements aujourd'hui m'ont dit ne
pas avoir de rentrer et je crois que
nous pouvons accepter cela comme une
fatalité et donc je veux ici dire à
l'ensemble des familles des associations
qui accompagnent du gouvernement que il
ya une mobilisation évidemment nationale
à faire sur ce sujet qui est très
importante
nous allons tâcher d'y jouer notre rôle
nous renforçons notre appui dans ce
domaine le ministre de l'europe et des
affaires étrangères a fait des annonces
importantes lorsqu'il est venu au mois
de juillet nous allons évidemment
compléter cet effort avec une
mobilisation de 7 millions d'euros
additionnels pour la réhabilitation des
établissements scolaires touchés par
l'explosion
l'accessibilité des manuels scolaires
20000 manuels ont été apportées lors de
notre déplacement particulier pour les
classes de terminale le soutien aux
familles fragilisées
le soutien aux étudiants le fonds de
soutien aux écoles chrétiennes les
francophones d'orient dont j'avais
annoncé la mise en place à jérusalem est
désormais pleinement opérationnel
il bénéficiera largement au liban
j'appelle les collectivités ainsi que
les donateurs privés qui veulent
s'engager à y contribuer nous
continuerons de pousser cet effort il
est absolument essentiel et nous allons
dans les prochaines semaines aussi
ajouté à l'effort pour les étudiants
libanais venant en france un dispositif
exceptionnel sera mobilisé pour
accroître le nombre de bourses mais
aussi régler le problème du coût des
études
surtout pour les familles dont
l'ensemble des économies sont bloqués au
libre sur la reconstruction qui est le
quatrième sujet sur lequel je voulais
ici insisté dans ce cadre nous
amplifions notre action sur le
déblaiement la réhabilitation des
logements et nous accompagnerons la
reconstruction du port de beyrouth ce
qui doit être fait dans l'intérêt du
peuple libanais et lui seul je le disais
plusieurs entreprises sont d'ores et
déjà mobilisés sur le site et saint
gobain qui étaient avec nous ce matin
beaucoup des ong d'associations font un
travail remarquable
le cds du quai d'orsay a beaucoup
coordonner cette aide comme toutes les
autres et je veux ici séduit son travail
mais au-delà de cette aide d'urgence à
la reconstruction doit s'organiser on a
vu travail de beaucoup de rng
exemplaires et donc pour les logements
il faut ici en quelque sorte ne pas
céder à ce qui pourrait être la facilité
de la fraternité d'ibanez les trois cent
mille personnes qui ont perdu leur
logement sont logés par des proches
il n'en demeure pas moins qu'elles n'ont
plus de logement et donc on doit
reconstruire vite pour qu'elles
retrouvent une vie normale en
particulier avec leurs enfants mais en
effet les grandes infrastructures
doivent être construites au plus vite
avec transparence célérité et là aussi
avec eux toutes les exigences de
sécurité qui sont dues aux libanaises
aux libanais je pense tout
particulièrement au port ça fait partie
des réformes d'ailleurs essentiels sur
lesquels nous sommes revus nous agissons
aussi pour préserver le patrimoine
libanais avec l'engagement immédiat et
concret de l'alliance internationale
pour la protection du patrimoine dans
les zones de conflits je veux saluer ici
la mobilisation de l'ihf la protection
du patrimoine était essentiel ça fait
partie de ses missions la cathédrale
saint-georges en particulier fera partie
des premiers projets et nous allons
continuer avec le ministère aussi des
affaires étrangères ministère de la
culture à mobiliser l'expertisé
française ainsi que des fonds pour
accompagner ses premiers travaux
la livre dont je veux une fois encore
salué l'engagement et le travail
au-delà de cet appui j'ai entendu ce qui
m'a été dit ce matin sur le port et je
retiens comme je vous le disais un
message très clair meilleure
coordination